foreign
getaway plans grounded again
after months of travel chaos and
cancellations British Airways has
suspended the sale of domestic and
European flights from Heathrow and now
Sky News understands it won't sell any
new short haul tickets until the 15th of
August
the airline says it's in response to a
cap on passenger numbers introduced by
Heathrow Airport which forced the
cancellation of thousands of flights the
suspension of ticket sales will allow it
to rebook those passengers affected more
easily
after huge disruption passenger numbers
at Heathrow are almost back up to
pre-pandemic levels the problem is the
number of ground staff working for
Airlines and baggage handling companies
hasn't recovered as well and is still
off by about 30 percent this is a big
problem for people who are hoping to
book in the next week but if you're
already booked on with a ba flight this
should give you a little bit more
confidence that if there's a
cancellation you have some room for
maneuver and as we're seeing more
airports introduce their passenger caps
and Airlines may have to follow in Ba's
footsteps and introduce this really
creative measure to try and give
themselves some predictability
this is the latest attempt by the
industry to get to grips with a crisis
caused by a lack of staff and more
passengers than Airlines and airports
can handle we've also had an Amnesty on
changing flight schedules and
cancellations caps on passenger numbers
at Heathrow Airport but each measure
creates knock-on effects more passengers
to be rebooked or compensated and that's
how we've got to this stage the risk is
this ends up hurting other Travelers as
it increases demand and prices for
competitors Services airfares will
Skyrocket now as a result of this
because there's less capacity for seats
to be available so this will force
airfares up and also because this is a
very short notice and the Outlook is
very uncertain there could be further
disruption
Heathrow has been heavily criticized by
some of its Airlines for the passenger
cap but it's not the only one
skipol airport in Amsterdam has also
limited passenger numbers and will
continue to till the end of October
but none of these measures will address
the underlying problem a lack of Staff
until that's sorted the risk of
disruption will continue through the
Autumn Madeleine Ratcliffe Sky News